The day is Jan 5th, 2012.
At an undisclosed offsite location, Dr. Bannon
leaves home and begins his commute to work.
While in the car he plays a video on his phone
of his 12 year old’s birthday party from
the previous night.
The sight of it makes him smile.
He would need that smile he thought, as today
was not like any other.
Today was different.
He had been anxious about the coming day for
several weeks now, ever since the near-unanimous
vote by the O5 Council that the containment
chamber of SCP-106 was to be re-opened.
The opportunity was “too great to be wasted”
they said.
The research that could be gained too tempting..
Studying SCP-106’s molecular makeup, it’s
unique ability to open a “pocket dimension”,
or even just the black sludge-like substance
that appeared whenever the subject traveled
through solid objects, was far too valuable
to science to be outweighed by its potential
for danger.
He pleaded with them.
Begged them.
But as Dr. Bannon and his team of 7 researchers
and accompaniment of 40 security personnel
began applying their protective equipment,
he couldn’t help but think that he could
have done more to stop this.
Only God knew how hard he had tried to make
them see reason.
He had seen what had happened in previous
containment breaches at the facility.
He had seen what it’d done to the poor members
of SCP staff that became it’s victims.
Fates worse than death.
Limbs.. a mangled mess of melted fused skin.
Faces sunken and hollow with eyes and tongues
burned out.
He shuddered to think of what would happen
if containment failed again this time.
But to spite his misgivings, he knew full
well that regardless of his participation,
this research mission would go on with or
without him.
And no one knew as much about containing SCP-106
than he did.
Slowly, they proceeded to dismantle each of
the containment facilities' outer barriers.
16 separate circular chambers surrounded SCP-106’s
inner containment facility, each filled with
a variety of different fluids.
Fluids in each chamber varied in consistency
and viscosity from ionized water to ammonia
to kerosene.
SCP-106 had the peculiar ability to be able
to change its molecular makeup to meld with
objects and phase through solid forms like
walls and doors.
It could literally melt into the space between
walls.
This made containing SCP-106 almost impossible
by conventional methods.
Liquids confused the creature enough to slow
him down.
In theory anyways.
The secondary containment chambers were a
recent addition to the facility since the
breach incident 3 years ago.
Dr. Bannon had been a new addition to the
research staff then.
He had joined the team with bright eyes and
a desire to use their research to help society.
Little did he know he would instead do everything
in his power to keep whatever they found from
ever leaving the facility.
Back then a breach in the containment of SCP-106
led to countless deaths of SCP personnel when
a researcher working on the top floor of the
outer layer of the containment facility, unknowing
of the danger they were in, brought his child
to work one day.
It was thought the outer layers of the facility
were enough to be considered a safe zone from
the inner vault that was SCP-106’s containment.
But it wasn’t enough to stop the Old Man.
SCP-106 preferred human prey between the ages
of 10 and 25.
And the sound of a child’s cry or yell was
enough to capture it’s immediate attention.
What proceeded was unimaginable horror.
But to spite the unfortunate events of the
previous breach, the expedition continued
their dissent into the bowels of the building.
After several hours of draining individual
fluid chambers one by one and inputting complex
codes and biometric scans from simultaneous
top security clearance personnel at a time,
the expedition team had eventually reached
the lower levels of SCP-106’s containment
facility.
Suspended in midair by ELO IID electromagnetic
supports, in the center of a vast subterranean
chamber, was a massive lead-lined steel cube,
40 layers thick, each layer separated by 36
cm of empty space, with support struts between
layers randomly spaced to confuse SCP-106
from being able to phase through one layer
to the next.
Surrounding the cube on every surface were
military grade automated light systems capable
of 80,000 lumens apiece, spaced every two
feet around the perimeter of the inner containment
chamber.
The team felt their resolve chip away the
closer they got to the suspended structure.
Dr. Bannon motioned to overhead surveillance
cameras above the cube and waited.
Slowly, the cube was lowered to the ground
until it hit the floor with a soft thud that
lightly rumbled the ground under the expedition
team’s feet.
With a resentful look up at the red dot on
the camera above, Dr. Bannon initiated the
Release Protocol.
All seven researchers input their key cards
and submitted themselves to retina scans as
the 40 security personnel established defensive
positions on every side of the lead-lined
cube.
For a moment, everyone held their breath in
silence.
You could almost feel the thumping of everyone’s
nervous heartbeats as they looked on to Dr.
Bannon as he pulled out his key card.
Everyone knew that as soon as it was scanned,
the barrier between them and The Old Man would
no longer exist.
If the rest of the personnel could see Bannon’s
hand shaking as he gripped the key card tightly
between his fingers, it would cause a possible
mass panic among the whole team.
As the spear-heading researcher on the job
that day, Bannon knew what he was up against
just the same as every one else, if not more.
He knew he couldn’t show the fear that was
pulsing through his veins.
This wasn’t his first rodeo here at the
Foundation.
He took a moment to collect his thoughts:
“Get ahold of yourself Bannon” He thought.
Dr. Bannon took a deep breath and scanned
the card.
The door slowly opened.
Armed with powerful rifle-length flashlights,
the researchers cautiously waded into the
dark entrance of the large cube.
Inside the structure they found a cell with
a solid steel door.
Signs of corrosion could be seen on the door’s
handle and the outer walls of the cell, rust
and rotted iron, but no breaches in the integrity
of the cell.
There were no more security codes at this
door.
It was a simple round metal turn lock.
Dr. Bannon swallowed, and began to turn the
handle open.
The sound of metal on metal echoed through
the chamber as the door creaked open, each
of the researchers immediately pointing their
flashlights into the room.
There in the corner, standing motionless and
undisturbed, stood SCP-106.
The Old Man.
He stood with eyes closed, locked in a dormant
state.
The researchers had planned for this.
SCP-106 spent up to 3 months at a time in
this subdued state in between periods of otherwise
“agitation”, where it would lash out at
it’s containment and attempt breach.
The research team wasted no time.
They began to collect data on the creature’s
biological makeup, taking whatever samples
they could from the walls and floors, and
recording photo and video of the specimen
while collecting any method of conventional
analysis they could manage under the given
circumstances.
Dr. Bannon kept an eye on the old man’s
face the entire time, refusing to look away
for one second for fear of it waking in the
absence of his gaze.
But to his relief, the creature did not stir,
and the data collection process went smoothly.
In a short period of time the team had packed
their gear and had proceeded to carefully
retreat from the inner chamber of the cube,
making sure to keep their lights pointed at
the creature the entire time.
Once the team exited the steel lined cube
they motioned again to the camera and the
huge heavy doors of the cube closed back in
on itself.
The electromagnetic supports came back online
and the cube was suspended once again in 3-dimensional
space without any immediate contact with solid
surfaces.
The security detail began packing up their
positions as everyone seemed to take a collective
sigh of relief.
That's when Dr. Bannon noticed the security
camera.
The red dot on the device had stopped blinking.
The camera was off.
A sudden feeling of dread entered Dr. Bannon’s
stomach as he turned in time to see all the
cameras around the room turning off.
Before he could react the chamber was plunged
into darkness as the electricity left the
room.
In the immediate darkness came a deafening
bang followed by a gust of wind and the weight
of a force strong enough to shake the ground
and knock the researchers off their feet.
The power to the electromagnetic supports
were down.
The cube had fallen.
Dr. Bannon shouted to his team to immediately
exit the facility.
He reached for his flashlight in the darkness.
He could hear screams in the background, gunfire.
He managed to illuminate the space in front
of him and saw his molecular biologist Dr.
Berns scrambling to get her gear back up over
her shoulder.
“Leave it!”, Dr. Bannon cried, only to
see a hand emerge from beneath her and pull
her down into a black viscous substance that
swallowed her whole and then vanished into
solid concrete.
After hearing the cries to his left he swung
his flashlight just in time to see him.
The old man had it’s hand on the chest of
a security personnel and entered him, exiting
through the other side leaving a gaping hole
in between.
Bullets were useless, as they seemed to get
trapped on entry of his body, slowly melting
into his skin.
SCP-106 then vanished into the floor and appeared
behind another member of the security detail,
grabbing him by the heel and dragging him
as he pleaded and reached out to Dr. Bannon
for help, pulling him halfway into the wall
and then letting go as the creature melted
into the space between the walls, leaving
behind half the poor man’s body bleeding
and still squirming to get away.
One by one he could hear his researchers crying
out for help before their voices were extinguished.
Before he could think of what to do next,
the power came back on, and light flooded
into the large room.
He gazed at the creature as it stood momentarily
stunned by the influx of light.
The old man had gaunt piercing hollow eyes
in a face covered in dark melting skin and
a lipless mouth that displayed terrible decaying
teeth.
It’s corrosive hand had a grasp on the arm
of Dr. Bryer, the physicist, burning the skin
beneath it’s grip as he cried out in pain.
And then, without warning, the creature placed
a hand on the wall of the metal cube and disappeared
into it, pulling the doctor in with him…
into the pocket dimension between the walls.
48 hrs later, in containment site 19, located
in the state of [data expunged], SCP personnel
open the door to an observation chamber where
SCP-049
is led in wearing steel covered hand restraints.
On the other side of a glass panel, Dr. Blake
sat impatiently, watching the humanoid creature
known as SCP-049, the “Plague Doctor”,
take a seat and face his direction.
Dr. Blake hesitated to address the entity
that sat in front of him.
But putting aside his reservations, he spoke
into the microphone.
Blake informed SCP-049 of the recent breach
that had transpired at the SCP-106 containment
site.
The doctor seemed intrigued at the news.
And when asked if he would provide assistance,
the doctor agreed.
SCP-049 had exhibited abilities to produce
instances of SCP-049-2, reanimated corpses
that he alone had the ability to control by
will.
In the past the Plague Doctor had been allowed
certain..privileges..deceased subjects for
the doctor to experiment on in his quest to
find a cure for what he referred to as “the
Pestilence”, though none of the researchers
could pinpoint exactly what the symptoms of
this perceived illness was or any specifics
about it at all.
However the supply of subjects was halted
after an incident where SCP-049 struck a personnel
member, killing him instantly with his “touch
of death”, an ability that ceases all bodily
function upon contact.
Since then the Plague Doctor refused to cooperate
unless he was provided with live subjects
for experimentation.
Up to this point, he had been denied.
But Dr. Blake needed the Plague Doctor’s
help.
And time was not on his side.
Dr. Blake agreed to provide SCP-049 with several
live D-Class personnel in return for his assistance.
As we’ve come to learn time and time again
here on SCP Explained, the Foundation has
no qualms about ridding the lives of these
ex-death row inmates.
D-Class are essentially the Foundation’s
lab rats and treating them as such is more
than worth it if dealing with an SCP-106 containment
breach.
Bring in the orange jumpsuits!
“Splendid!”
remarked 049.
The Plague Doctor was taken to the secret
site of SCP-106’s containment facility and
briefed on The Old Man’s ability to meld
and travel between walls, floors, and solid
surfaces.
As well as its ability to pull objects into
its own pocket dimension, of which there was
little information about.
SCP-049 grew more and more intrigued by the
description of the old man.
Upon arriving, a laboratory was prepared at
the site for SCP-049.
For proxies to serve as lures to bait SCP-106,
the team procured the bodies of a recent public
transportation bus wreckage that had left
12 younger adults dead.
As the Plague Doctor began his surgeries on
them, Doctor Bannon could think only of the
prior containment breach.
The staff suffered many casualties to personnel.
And ever since then anyone under the age of
30 were banned entry within 20 miles of the
containment site.
Just as Doctor Bannon began to rub his temple
thinking about how they managed to return
SCP-106 to his cell that day, there was yell
of excitement:
“Marvelous!”
cried out SCP-049.
The Plague Doctor informed SCP staff that
he had finished his work and the surgeries
had been of paramount success.
The doctor had indeed produced 12 instances
of SCP-049-2 as predicted.
The subjects were horrid abominations.
Some with inverted faces and others with added
appendages and gaping holes where limbs should
be.
But they were ambient.
And the research staff would soon learn if
they would be enough to lure SCP-106 back
into containment.
Staring at the dimly lit white room crowded
with malformed ambient corpses, Dr. Bannon
couldn’t help but feel a sense of dread
fill the pit of his stomach.
But there was no time to second guess.
With rifles and flashlights in hand the team
led the troop of SCP-049-2s out and down the
concrete hallways and into a large freight
elevator that led down to the vast chamber
that housed the inner containment cube that
was SCP-106’s home since arriving at the
facility.
The drone-like -2s did not speak during this
trip.
They did not blink.
They simply stared straight ahead and acted
at the behest of the Plague Doctor without
any verbal input.
The macabre parade arrived at the entrance
of the cube and proceeded inside.
Dr, Bannon informed SCP-049 that the -2s needed
to make noises of some kind, to cry out if
they could.
Anything would work, as long as it was audible
enough.
The Plague Doctor nodded his head.
And all 12 of the reanimated corpses began
to scream in terrifying unison.
In the hollow distance, a roar was heard in
response.
It dripped from the ceiling.
First a drop, then many more until a puddle
formed on the ground in front of the cube,
the Plague Doctor approaching with intrigue.
Out of the floor rose up the creature known
as SCP-106, coming face to face with the Plague
Doctor.
Upon seeing the creature, SCP-049 was ecstatic.
He began to examine SCP-106 closely without
fear of bodily harm.
With lightning speed he produced a vial and
pincers from a medicine bag of black leather
he kept under his robes and snatched a sample
of the creature’s black viscous skin.
The Plague Doctor was overjoyed:
“This will lead to my greatest work, and
the cure for the Pestilence once and for all!”
But the old man did not seem to acknowledge
or enjoy the presence of SCP-049 and reacted
violently, lashing out to strike the Plague
Doctor.
Sensing danger, 049 jumped back and willed
the 049-2s to attack the creature.
But before they could reach it, SCP-106 melted
into a pool of black and disappeared into
the floor.
The instances looked around dazed.
Another black pool appeared under one of them,
causing it to fall into the portal and then
fall out from the ceiling elsewhere in the
vast stadium-sized room.
Another pool opened under one of the ambient
thralls, sucking it down into the black abyss.
And then another.
And another.
And soon loud thuds could be heard echoing
through the chamber as bodies began to appear
from the top of the hundred foot ceiling,
falling to a splatter on the concrete floor
below.
Upon witnessing SCP-106’s abilities first
hand, SCP-049 nodded to Dr. Bannon as he swiftly
packed up his medicine bag and made for the
door, only to be blocked by SCP-106’s materializing
form.
The Plague Doctor grew angry and struck the
neck of the old man with his cold touch of
death.
But it seemed to have no effect on SCP-106.
The black substance on his body started to
creep up over 049’s hand, sizzling and searing
skin and flesh as it went up the forearm.
Sensing danger, the Plague Doctor pulled out
a large scalpel and in one quick motion sliced
off his own arm at the elbow.
The severed limb fell to the floor, engulfed
by the black bubbling substance.
SCP-106 then lunged at the Doctor who’s
quick agility allowed him to dodge and make
for the doorway.
Once in the hall SCP-049 quickly pulled out
a roll of brown gauze from his medical bag
and began to wrap his bleeding wound tight
as he hurried through the dimly lit corridor,
lights flickering on and off.
As SCP-049 turned a corner a black substance
appeared on the wall in front of him and a
chair came flying out of it towards his head.
The Doctor dodged it but did not dodge a sharp
metal spike that materialized from another
hole appearing on the wall to his left.
It pierced the outside of his knee, causing
his movement to be slowed.
Hearing the sound of clanking metal, the doctor
looked up in time to see a desk falling out
of another dimensional portal above him.
He managed to roll sideways, missing the blow,
but straight into another of SCP-106’s portals,
causing the doctor to fall through the wall
and into the floor of the room below.
With a falling crash the doctor landed in
the lower room and looked around quickly seeking
to regain his footing.
The old man was nowhere to be seen, but he
could hear him, bumping in the darkness, traveling
through the walls of the building.
The Plague Doctor quickly analyzed the office
room for something useful.
On the wall he found a map of the facility
and studied the schematics.
On the floor was a dead body.
He crouched down close to it and stabbed it
with a syringe from his cloak, animating the
corpse and commanding it to run, serving as
a distraction to lead SCP-106 away so he could
make it to the adjoining hallway just a few
hundred feet away.
That was the armory.
Limping from his injured leg, the Plague Doctor
waited for the old man to be led away as he
made it to the room.
He began tearing through the weaponry that
lined and leaned up against the walls in every
direction, ignoring the automatic rifles as
they were useless.
Then he found what he had been searching for.
Flash grenades.
As the form of another black portal began
to materialize in front of him, he pulled
the pin and tossed the grenade in the putrid
puddle.
A blast of light erupted from within, followed
by the sound of the creature recoiling in
pain.
The Plague Doctor pulled another pin.
And another.
And in this manner he led SCP-106 toward the
secondary containment facilities that had
begun filling with fluid.
When he reached a level where he could recognize
the smell of kerosine, he stopped.
There he waited, as SCP-106 emerged from the
darkness in front of him.
It snarled and howled, spitting black bits
of tar as it’s gnarling yellowed teeth came
close to the Plague Doctor’s face.
The Plague Doctor calmly turned and waded
out of the half-filled room.
SCP-106 tried to lunge at him, to follow.
But it could not.
It found itself rooted in liquid, unable to
easily open a portal into the space between
the walls.
Stepping out of the room, the Plague Doctor
reached into his cloak and pulled out a large
match from his leather bag.
Without glancing back he struck the match
and gave a ginger toss into the flames, sliding
the door closed behind him.
The resulting explosion and subsequent inferno
damaged the walls of the secondary containment
facility and caused significant seismic activity
within the outer walls of the containment
site.
Emergency lights flickered on and off in the
darkness and debris rained down from the ceiling
in every direction.
In this haze of rubble, the Plague Doctor
picked himself up off the ground and began
to dust his cloak clean with the one hand
he had left.
Satisfied, he took a content sigh and began
to make for the exit to the outside world,
where he would resume his quest to rid the
Earth of the Pestilence that plagued mankind.
Though..
An unexpected surprise made him pause.
A flaming corpse began to emerge from a black
hole in the wall beside him.
SCP-106, intact and whole, the flames slowly
seeping into his skin until they were all
extinguished, and only smoke rose from his
body.
This time the doctor was not so fast to react.
The creature grabbed him by the face and slammed
it into a nearby wall, cracking the marble
surface.
The black substance pooled around the Plague
Doctor’s face.
SCP-106 opened a portal in the wall, pushing
the Doctor's head into it.
The events that followed afterwards are difficult
to put together, as camera footage from the
facility suffered severe damage due to SCP-049’s
explosion of the secondary containment chambers.
SCP-106 was found back inside his cell in
the containment cube, back to his dormant
state where he would remain for the next few
months.
That is..until he would feel the need to hunt
prey once again..
As the doors of the 40-layer steel cube closed,
the electromagnetic supports came back online,
and the fluid chambers repaired and refilled.
The committee is currently voting on whether
or not to allow SCP-106’s containment facility
to be opened again.
For now, The world could rest once more, Dr.
Bannon could take a sigh of relief.
But for how long..he thought.
For that, there was no way to tell..
Now go check out “SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured” and “SCP-106 - The Old Man Escape”
for more tales of your favorite anomalous
entities from SCP Explained!